the Wildfire began on Wednesday evening
by Thursday the blaze fanned by strong
offshore winds and dry conditions grew
to 40 square kilometers the National
Weather Service say conditions are right
for large and dangerous fire growth
thousands of residents of being told to
leave their homes as the flames spread
there's a lot of work that's been done
to not only coordinate outreach to our
vulnerable population care homes but
also make sure that our fire stations
are water stations our sewer lift
stations are all going to be functioning
to the duration of this outage rolling
blackouts designed to help stop the
blaze spreading are in place from the
Sierra Foothills to portions of the San
Francisco Bay Area the power cuts are
affecting half a million people across
15 counties with more expected this
weekend
electricians like Javier Gutierrez are
working long hours to help communities
facing dangerous conditions last two
weeks ago was really a nightmare for me
since I've been getting forecast since 4
o'clock in the morning trying to get
generators hooked up so far the Kincaid
fire is zero percent contained and
things could get worse forecasters say
the so-called Santa Ana winds will be
even stronger in the coming days
hampering efforts to fight fires in a
state that's been plagued by them in
recent years two years ago the tubs fire
raged through the same area killing at
least 22 people and destroying over
5,000 homes conditions now are said to
be almost identical and a Galica al
Jazeera